bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans quelques instants vous allez
pouvoir suivre la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires ce matin à la discussion
reprend à l'article 28 avec le vote d'un
amendement déposé par le gouvernement
il vise à encadrer la préparation et la
distribution de médicaments dans les
établissements du secteur médico social
bonne séance à tous l'ordre du jour un
peu la suite de la discussion du projet
de loi portant réforme de l'hôpital et
relatif aux patients à la santé et aux
territoires
dans la discussion des articles sont
parvenues au synthétique 28 l'amendement
du gouvernement 171 amendement qui a été
présenté et sur lequel madame
desmarécaux nous a présenté un
sous-amendement et nous avons arrêté la
discussion la laissant à la nuit la
capacité de trouver la rédaction qui
ferait l'admiration des foules
alors où en sommes nous et qui demande
la parole puisque on avait une
proposition de rectification du
sous-amendement madame la ministre vous
nous faites le le point où en sommes
nous
désolé monsieur le président je il faut
que je me retrouve dans mes documents en
ce début de séance
mais c'est bon alors alors monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
madame le sénateur sylvie daigle
desmarécaux alors comme je lai indiqué
le gouvernement rejoint totalement la
commission dans sa préoccupation de
tenir compte des besoins
d'accompagnement des personnes privées
d'autonomie dans les gestes de la vie
quotidienne
c'est bien sûr le bon sens que de
considérer que l'aide à la prise de
médicaments apportées par les personnes
chargées de l'aide aux actes de la vie
courante entre dans ce cadre
le texte de la commission a pris la
précaution de préciser qu'il ne s'agit
que des modes de prise ne présentant ni
difficulté d'administration nous
d'apprentissage particulier ce qui
exclut par exemple bien sûr les
injections
le texte précise également que des
protocoles de soins viennent encadrer
ces pratiques
une seule difficulté demeure peut-être
que l'amendement du gouvernement tente à
lever mais qui appelle je le vois des
explications complémentaires en
proposant de ne retenir que la notion d'
aide à la prise de médicaments
le gouvernement entend simplement éviter
les possibles ambiguïté engendrés par le
terme distribution il est clair que
l'aide à la prise de médicaments
comprend la distribution au sens de
remise à la personne aidée il ne s'agit
pas d'interdire à l'aidant de porter et
de remettre à la personne aidée le
médicament sélectionnés par l'infirmière
on est bien là dans l'aide aux gestes de
la vie courante
en revanche il faut éviter de laisser
penser que les préparations le
conditionnement dans un pilulier ou a
fortiori la sélection du médicament dans
son lieu de rangement sont laissées à
l'initiative de l'aidant c'est cet
aspect plus technique du mot
distribution qui pourrait porter à
confusion
c'est donc au ses bénéfices de ces
explications que je vous propose
d'adopter
l'amendement du gouvernement et de
demander à madame le sénateur civi
d'érable marécaux que je que je remercie
d'avoir au travers de son initiative et
du débat soulevé cette question et nous
de nous avoir demandé d'en apporter des
précisions très clair qui seront donc
portée de toute façon aux comptes rendus
au journal officiel et permettront
d'avancer très clairement sur le
contexte qui va permettre d'accompagner
les établissements d médico-sociaux qui
comme vous l'avez rappelé ont besoin de
clarifications sur ces questions
c'est voilà madame le sénateur ce que je
voulais vous apporter comme précision
en vous demandant si vous acceptez donc
de retirer le sous-amendement au
gouvernement au vu de ces
éclaircissements
merci on a misé madame les mariko
collègues le propos que vous avez tenus
ce matin la nuit a peut-être permis de
réfléchir monsieur frimas
mais ça ne m'a pas empêché de bien
dormir je vous remercie simplement de
vous dire mes ministres vos propos sont
rassurants sont claires et au regard de
tout ce que vous avez dit qui sera
repris donc au journal officiel vous
satisfait complètement ma demande et je
vous remercie donc d'être intervenu dès
ce matin pour conforter ce dont j'avais
des battus merci merci madame la
sénatrice donc le sous-amendement 1354
héros de tirer je veux mettre aux voix
l'amendement du gouvernement 1171 qui
est pour
je vous en prie aime chez leclerc
je suis tout ouïe
monsieur le président je suis désolé que
notre collègue madame desmarescaux vient
d'enlever son amendement mais je voulais
m'exprimer dessus et je mets en garde le
gouvernement sur la rédaction qui nous
propose aujourd'hui ayant quand même
l'habitude de voir la délivrance des
médicaments dans les établissements quel
qu'il soit je voudrais quand même vous
mettre en garde car mais si madame en
dehors aujourd'hui de la logique il y a
des génériques il ya des confusions tels
que si vous laissez toute personne
habilitée
même en ayant sélectionné auparavant par
des piluliers et toute méthode autres
dans le quotidien il y à de nombreuses
erreurs c'est pas grave la personne
absorbe comme elle prend cinq six sept
huit pilules différentes le matin qui en
a une ou deux qui ne conviennent pas eu
globalement eu sa carte de santé
publique je trouve quand même ça énorme
je pense que la dispensation du
médicament dans un établissement quel
qu'il soit de se faire par des personnes
ayant un minimum de connaissances et de
diplo très bien je vais m madame la
ministre je vous en prie simplement pour
dire à monsieur le sénateur leclerc que
hier soir
toutes ces questions étaient largement
débattue et justement
l'amendement qui était présenté par le
gouvernement visait justement à aa à
contenir et justement à préciser les
intentions qui ont été mis dans le texte
par la commission et tout le débat que
nous venons d'avoir justement vise à
sécuriser aller dans le sens de ce que
vous évoquez monsieur le sénateur c'est
pour cette raison que je pense que les
choses sont très très clairs et
qu'encore une fois les explications
données permettent de rassurer y compris
sur ce que vous venez d'évoquer pour
éviter toute ambiguïté pour
l'explication ne veut que la parole du
gouverneur que je crois je crois qu'il
faut faire la part des choses
on trouvera pas moyenne de retour et gré
parce que ça c'est les impondérables
j'espère qu'à vous même monsieur leclerc
que dans les médicaments qu'ils prennent
ya pas des médicaments sous dit
ils en prennent un coup
de temps en temps qui ne sont pas dans
le lot ça m'inquiète là mais le
finalement l'amendement présenté par
madame la ministre est simple ils pas
complet en fait ils règlent à peu près
le problème
après bien sûr les impondérables c'est
pour ça que nous le voterons très bien
alors je veux m'assurer que personne une
intervention entrée sur ce sujet
important
je vous en donne acte devait donc le
mettre aux voix qui et pour qui et
comprend qu'il est adoptée nous en
arrivons un amendement 1335 plus que le
rapporteur monsieur le président merci
juste c'est un amendement de précision
juridique
sachant que le 20e en d'articles 28
créer un statut des établissements
sociaux et médico-sociaux privé
d'intérêt collectif
étant donné que le code de l'action
sociale et des familles place au même
plan juridique la notion d'établissement
sociaux médico-sociaux et celles de
services sociaux médico-sociaux et est
logique que ces derniers soient
concernés par le nouveau statut
merci au sonar de mam ministre avis
favorable monsieur le président merci
y at il des explications de vote je n'en
vois pas je le vois qui est pour et qui
est contre
il est adopté deux amendements
identiques en discussion commune
amendement 977 madame david ne vous
écoute on merci monsieur le président
madame à nice mes chers collègues la
disposition que nous souhaitons
supprimés par cet amendement tend à
instaurer un service minimum dans les
établissements accueillant de façon
permanente des personnes âgées et
handicapées
une fois n'est pas coutume non pas
aujourd'hui monsieur le rapporteur
une fois n'est pas coutume nous avons
déposé cet amendement et avons constaté
avec étonnement que mal le gouvernement
on avait décidé de nous suivre puisque
vous avez à votre tour déposé un
amendement similaire au nôtre c'était
pour la forme vous l'aurez compris et
j'en viens au fond si nous avons déposé
cet amendement c'est que nous
considérons que s'il est effectivement
nécessaire de prévoir des modalités
permettant l'accueil et le soin des
personnes prises en charge dans les
établissements médico sociaux notamment
au regard de l'importance de certaines
pathologies
il n'est pas souhaitable de renvoyer les
modalités de l'instauration de ce
service minimum au silence d'un décret
alors qu'il pourrait revêtir une
véritable privation du droit de grève
pourtant le dialogue social chère à
xavier bertrand ancien ministre
en tout cas cher à notre commission des
affaires sociales ne saurait être
bafouer de la sorte en attend en
adoptant donc cet amendement nous
entendons renvoyé le gouvernement à la
négociation que nous considérons comme
indispensable nous demandons pour cet
amendement la tenue d'un scrutin public
bien alors nous avons un amendement
identique qui est du gouvernement un
amendement 1168 le ministre oui monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs le texte de la commission vise
à faire figurer les établissements
privés chargés d'une mission d'intérêt
général tels que mentionnés à l'article
l 311 1 du code de l'action sociale et
des familles
parmi les établissements qu'elle
s'applique les dispositions
particulières du travail pour l'exercice
du droit de grève dans les services
publics notamment obligation d'un
préavis de grève tel qu'il rédigeait ses
dispositions ne viserait pas seulement
les établissements et services
accompagnant de façon permanente des
personnes âgées ou handicapées mais
l'ensemble des établissements et
services intervenant dans le champ de
l'action sociale et médico sociale y
compris des services administratifs et
des établissements et services sociaux
et médico-sociaux n'accompagnons pas des
personnes
âgées ou handicapées exemple chrs foyer
de jeunes travailleurs puisque tous
exercent cette mission d'intérêt général
je comprends la préoccupation de la
commission qui est aussi la mienne de
s'assurer de la continuité de la prise
en charge des soins des personnes
fragiles accueillis dans les
établissements médico sociaux
il convient cependant d'adapter la
réponse apportée à la situation
objective jusqu'ici rencontré et de
tenir compte des solutions déjà offerte
par la législation pour garantir cette
continuité aux usagers qui ne peuvent
sans risque ni dommage pour leur santé
ou leur autonomie voire leur prise en
charge interrompu ou dégradés s'agissant
des établissements et services
médico-sociaux de statut privé très
majoritaire dans le secteur des
personnes handicapées et représentant
près de la moitié des institutions pour
personnes âgées n'existe pas de
restrictions à l'exercice du droit de
grève
cependant le préfet détient au titre de
ses pouvoirs de police un pouvoir de
réquisition prévu au 4ème mans de
l'article l
22 15 1 du code général des
collectivités locales dès lors qu'il y a
urgence est atteinte constatée ou
prévisible à la sécurité des personnes
et qu'il n'a pas d'autre moyen pour
exercer ses pouvoirs de police
ces dispositions ont paru permettre de
considérer ce fait du droit de grève
garanti par la constitution et
sauvegarde de la sécurité des personnes
accompagnées par les établissements et
services concernés
conscient des missions d'intérêt général
et d'utilité sociale que la loi du 2
janvier 2002 confie aux institutions
sociales et médico sociale et de leur
responsabilité particulière à l'égard
des personnes fragiles auprès desquels
ils interviennent les responsables de
ces établissements et professionnels
concernés ont toujours montré dans leur
immense majorité leur volonté leur
capacité même en cas de conflit du
travail de ne pas porter atteinte aux
besoins essentiels des personnes âgées
ou handicapées accueillies
ce n'est que très exceptionnellement que
les préfets ont été conduits envisager
des réquisitions faut-il face à des
incidents aujourd'hui heureusement très
isolée restreindre le droit de grève est
imposé un service minimum sur ce sujet
complexe potentiellement conflictuelles
et où nous avons
fois le devoir d'assurer la sécurité des
usagers en situation de fragilité et de
nous concerter avec les partenaires du
secteur
le gouvernement propose de mettre en
place une mission d'expertisé associant
les interlocuteurs concernés
elle pourrait tout d'abord vérifier si
les dispositions actuelles garantissent
effectivement la sécurité et la réponse
aux besoins essentiels l'accompagnement
des usagers recommandé d instruction
facilitant l'application et le contrôle
de ces règles recensé ou proposer des
outils et des marchés existants ou à
créer permettant en amont d'organiser
dans les institutions la continuité des
missions essentielles des établissements
et services médico sociaux pour les
publics fragiles analyser les
conséquences juridiques de la
reconnaissance actuelle par la loi d'une
mission d'intérêt général est d'utilité
collective au regard de la continuité
des missions
enfin proposer si le constat était fait
d'une insuffisance de la législation et
réglementation actuelle les textes
permettant d'y remédier la mission d'
expertise associant les interlocuteurs
concernés sera mise en place avant l'été
et ses conclusions devront être remises
avant la fin de l'année dans l'attenté
de ces résultats
je vous demande de bien vouloir adopter
l'amendement de suppression déposé par
le gouvernement au vu des garanties qui
sont données et des délais qui sont
fixés dans mon argumentaire c'est à dire
que ce n'est pas une mission en l'air on
s'engage véritablement avant l'été de
l'organiser et que ses conclusions
soient rendues avant la fin de l'année
voilà ce que je à vous proposer mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs très bien leurs
ministres un amour / sur ces amendements
l'avis de la commission
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
tout d'abord rappelé madame david
si la commission a adopté ce texte ce
n'est pas sur un amendement du
gouvernement mais un amendement de
madame desmarécaux est resté que je
remercie d'avoir mis en place le moment
donc pour répondre à au groupe crc spg
cet amendement qui votera moment donc il
dispose de supprimer la disposition
introduite par la commission portant sur
l'instauration du service minimum
il semble aujourd'hui indispensable de
garantir un service minimum dans ces
établissements
en effet déclenchement d'une grève peut
conduire à une moins de prise en charge
des usagers mettant une fine et leur vie
en danger en prévoyant d'abord une
solution négociée avec les partenaires
sociaux la mesure proposée ainsi qu'au
dialogue social dans les établissements
médico-sociaux elle constitue donc pour
la commission une solution équilibrée
entre le respect dû à une grève des
personnels et la garantie la sécurité
des personnes dépendantes et la
commission émet un avis défavorable pour
ce qui est d'un amendement du
gouvernement qui propose de supprimer la
même disposition estimant que cette
question doit faire l'objet d'une
mission d'expertisé associant les
interlocuteurs concernés pour les mêmes
raisons la mea commission a émis un avis
défavorable à l'or
en heure sur ces deux amendements un
avis défavorable de la commission de la
ministre je suppose que vous donner un
avis favorable sur l'amendement du
identique aux autres
il est identique donc satisfait par
l'amendement du gouvernement qui donne
des précisions ensuite sur la traduction
sur la justification de la demande
justement de de retrait de cet article
c'est pourquoi effectivement il est
satisfait très bien alors
donc nous allons passer mes chers
collègues fixation de vote j'ai vu
d'abord le président fischer puis
monsieur fourcade
si les verts notre monsieur daudigny
président me très attachés à cet
amendement de suppression car bon je ne
vais pas relancé tout le débat sur le
service minimum mais je crois que dans
le contexte actuel nous sommes très
sensibles surtout à la veille du débat
sur le travail du dimanche et nous
savons et l'expérience d'ailleurs je
remercie madame la ministre d'avoir
argumenté dans le même sens que nous
c'est à dire à partir des expériences
on sait bien que l'institution du
service minimum dans ce secteur du
médico-social et bien véritablement ce
n'est pas à partir de quelques exemples
totalement exceptionnel mais je crois
que tous les personnels tous ceux qui
travaillent dans ce secteur ont toujours
eu le sens de l'intérêt général tout le
temps et c'est pour cela que nous voyons
à travers les propositions qui avaient
été faites par même debré monsieur
vasselle
mais surtout on voit bien que la
commission à travers son rapporteur et
bien tient véritablement à cette
institution d'un service minimum
nous nous ne pouvons absolument pas
accepter cela le dialogue social a
toujours prévalu
je crois que c'est un secteur où qui a
fait preuve d'ailleurs de responsabilité
depuis très longtemps et c'est pour cela
que nous maintenons néanmoins notre
demande de scrutin public sur en fait
ces deux amendements de suppression car
il y a
cette volonté affirmée et je crois que
dans le contexte actuel où il s'agit de
des manques les absolument tous les
droits sociaux on détricote le droit du
travail constamment et on arrive
finalement en termes de travail et on
sait bien que dans le secteur
médico-social et bien la
professionnalisation de tous les
personnels
on en est loin il y à une précarité qui
est très grande et nous n'entendons pas
véritablement remettre cela en cause
c'est pour cela que nous sommes
absolument pour la suppression de ces
deux amendements et monsieur le
rapporteur way pour l'adoption ces deux
amendements pardon mais non mais je
crois que oui c'est ça un lapsus mais il
faut que je monte en pression corps
sains et donc nous nous regrettons
vivement la position qu'a prise la
commission et cela je crois que ce n'est
pas dans la tonalité qui a pu prévaloir
dans certains débats très vifs et cela
c'est pour ça que nous demandons
l'adoption ces amendements de
suppression
merci mon cher collègue pour expliquer
sur votre fenêtre jean pierre foucault
cup
je vous remercie monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
faisant écho à ce que vient de dire le
président fischer nous nous pensons que
il faut au contraire maintenir la
position de la commission des finances
car je n'ai nullement été rassurés par
la position du gouvernement
en effet en effet nous sommes ici pour
défendre les patients c'est le texte
nous sommes ici pour défendre les
patients et dans ma longue expérience g
si monsieur aussi occupé deux
établissements médico sociaux dans
lesquels j'ai eu des rêves et par
conséquent je crois que la position de
la commune à la commission des finances
est tout à fait légitime dont nous
soutenons la position de la commission
si le gouvernement veut faire sa mission
d'experts
libre à lui et nous serons tout à fait
d'accord pour modifier le texte après
mais je trouve que ce serait donner un
très mauvais signal à supprimer ce qu'a
fait la commission la réforme
constitutionnelle veux que nous
discutions sur la base du texte élaboré
par la commission la commission élabore
un texte le groupe ump soutient la
position de la commission madame la
ministre j'en suis navré mais je crois
que vos explications
quoique très très bien fondé ne
permettent pas de voter
votre amendement comme si j'ai encore
inscrits monsieur dowd signé monsieur
vasselle et après je vous aime la parade
a mis sous toit qu'on entende tout
légation notre merci monsieur le
président madame is mes chers collègues
je veux dire que nous soutiendrons les
deux amendements celui déposé par madame
david l'amendement du gouvernement et je
veux dire que je partage
l'argumentation qui a été présentée par
monsieur fisher
nous sommes ici sur une disposition qui
ne tend pas à régler des problèmes mais
qui est d'ordre idéologique comme cela a
été souligné précédemment des
circonstances où il ya des problèmes
sont rares
et lorsque 6e constance existe il y a
toujours la possibilité pour le préfet
de procéder par acquisition ou cas par
cas nous sommes donc bien ici dans le
cadre d'une mesure qui est d'ordre
symbolique je le disais idéologique et
qui ne correspond pas du tout à la
résolution d'un problème qui ne se pose
pas dans les abysses mans médico sociaux
donc nous soutiendrons bien les deux
amendements
merci monsieur des lignes monsieur
vasselle de notre rapide monsieur le
président madame le ministre mes chers
collègues pour confirmer la position qui
a été développée devant vous par le
monsieur fourcade président fourcade
nous soutiendrons donc la commission des
affaires sociales et son amendement et
je me permets de faire remarquer quand
même à nos collègues qui ne s'agit pas
d'une mesure à caractère purement
biologique ça répond à une demande des
familles je puis vous dire quand c'est
une concerne j'ai vécu cette situation
dans la commune où j'ai un foyer
occupationnel ou du jour au lendemain
les syndicats n'ayant pas annoncé au
préalable le mouvement grève de bouvent
grève a été décidée a été découvert le
matin même la directrice de
l'établissement appelant toutes les
parents en leur demandant de venir
chercher leurs enfants ou leurs jeunes
adultes parce que des plus de personnel
pour s'occuper donc de ces jeunes
adultes de ses enfants
on ne peut pas rester dans une telle
situation et jeudi à madame le ministre
a dans la mesure où dans la rédaction du
texte inédit
à défaut d'accord de branche ou
d'accords d'entreprise ou
d'établissement définissant les
modalités d'un service le service
minimum se met en place ce qui veut dire
qu'il suffit que les partenaires sociaux
se mettent autour de la table pour se
mettre d'accord dans le cadre d'un
accord collectif ou de négociations
conventionnelles pour mettre en place ce
service minimum donc il s'agit pas de
leur mettre le couteau sur la gorge
qu'il prenne l'initiative de cette
rencontre et auquel cas la concertation
que vous souhaitez madame le ministre
aura bien effectivement lieu simplement
si vous voulez être à la présidente de
ces concertations il suffit de se mettre
en rapport et les partenaires sociaux
pour que s'ils se passe si se passe dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
madame la ministre
oui monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs eh bien écoutez
pour ma part mon souhait n'est pas de
rentrer dans un débat idéologique pour
ou contre le service minimum comme ça a
été dit par les uns ou les autres régler
des problèmes purement concret des
problèmes de la vie quotidienne et de
préservation effectivement de la qualité
de la prise en charge des usagers
aujourd'hui on a eu
dans cet hémicycle des positions qui ont
été pris sur le service minimum sur son
utilité sa non utilité moi ce que je
voudrais vous proposer
c'est tout simplement de faire en sorte
que au travers d'une proposition qui
était très clair très lisible dont on a
déjà débattu en commission des affaires
sociales qui n'est pas un faux fuyant
qui vise juste à faire en sorte que
avant de prendre une décision
et si véritablement il y à des
situations concrètes et des
établissements qui se trouvent dans
cette situation particulière et bien
qu'on puisse véritablement examiné de la
façon très précise dont je les
présentais dans l'argumentaire du
gouvernement
ces aspects là au sein d'une mission
bien sûr les parlementaires seront
associés mais aussi les partenaires
sociaux consulter sur la démarche à
mettre en oeuvre et que au terme de
cette mission nous aurons tous là toute
la possibilité à ce moment de proposer
une mesure qui permettra de régler cette
situation
simplement je me suis permis au nom du
gouvernement de proposer cette solution
alternative pour qu'elle règle un
problème de bon sens mais en prenant le
temps de l'examiner de façon très
précise et en faisant en sorte à terme
de prendre les bonnes décisions et les
bonnes mesures dans l'intérêt des
usagers que bien sûr nous partageons
tous
mais simplement de le faire en prenant
la précaution d'associer l'ensemble des
acteurs partenaires sociaux
établissements parlementaire pour le
faire dans le bon sens simplement voilà
la précision que je souhaitais apporter
et la justification de ma demande de
retrait maintenant bien
les sénateurs sont en possession
effectivement de tous les éléments et je
me remets à leur choix très bien et bien
il est procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions fixées par l'article 56
du règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter
pour remettront secrétaires un bulletin
blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
un bulletin bleu ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir à multi rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
puisqu'aujourd'hui merci
c'est
échoué
c'est un clown invite mesdames et
messieurs le secrétaire a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
on
d'un numéro 171 sur les amendements 977
et en 168 ans de votants 341 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 341 majorité absolue
171 pour l'adoption 153 contre 188
le sénat n'a pas adopté alors nous avons
maintenant deux amendements discussion
commune un amendement 1134 qui est
présenté par un amèrement ge
oui nous avions déjà débattu dans le
cadre du plfss de cet amendement qui
avait quelque part été voté à
l'unanimité
et puis en cmp il y avait eu quelques
quelques problèmes et donc aujourd'hui
nous retrouvons avec la problématique de
l'hébergement temporel temporaire la
commission des affaires sociales a
approuvé le principe d'une
expérimentation comparative de plusieurs
modalités de fonctionnement et de
tarification pour l'accueil temporaire
médicalisé des personnes âgées et cet
amendement prend en compte le fait
aujourd'hui qu'un texte réglementaire
est déjà en cours de préparation donc
débats que nous avons eus dans le cadre
du plfss n'était pas inutile qui
permettra donc de créer une tarification
attractive pour ce type d'hébergement
sans passer par le stade d'une phase
expérimentale tel est l'objet de
l'amendement et je constate aussi que
monsieur autain a déposé quasiment le
même amendement
merci mon genre amendement 980 1
il est présenté par le groupe sears et
ses hôtes un et vous présenter la main
c'est parce que fischer
oui alors avec cet amendement
nous entendons appliquer aux personnes
âgées un dispositif prévu par la loi
2000 2-2 du 2 janvier 2002 qui rénovent
l'action sociale et médico sociale qui
comme vous le savez a reconnu l'accueil
temporaire et médicalisé les personnes
handicapées comme un élément de soutien
aux personnes handicapées et surtout à
leurs familles la loi a ensuite par
analogie étendu ce dispositif temporaire
est médicalisé aux personnes âgées
toutefois force est de constater qu'il
existe un important décalage entre la
volonté des acteurs publics de
développer de tels hébergement
médicalisée elle et création effective
cela se traduit par les dans les faits
par une utilisation plus que partiel des
fonds qui lui sont spécifiquement dédiés
à l'article r 314 9 114 du code de
l'action sociale et des familles en juin
2008 une étude a été menée par un
organisme de prévoyance propre secteur
du bâtiment est publié dans la presse
spécialisée
elle apporte des éléments
d'éclaircissement sur les causes de
cette situation et élabore des pistes de
réponses
parmi les réponses proposées figurent en
bonne place l'idée de retenir pour les
personnes âgées accueillies dans les
hébergements médicalisé temporaire les
mêmes dispositions en termes de
financement et de tarification que ce
qui est prévu pour les personnes
handicapées notamment à l'article r 314
194 du code de l'action sociale et des
familles
c'est ce que nous proposons avec cet
amendement
merci
non ses collègues monsieur l'un porte
sur la vie de l'un commission monsieur
le président je vais répondre aux deux
en même temps ce sont des amendements
qui comme vous l'avez remarqué propose
donc que dispositions réglementaires
régissant l'accueil temporaire des
personnes handicapées soit adapté afin
de les rendre habitables structures
d'accueil temporaire des personnes âgées
donc sur le fond cette mesure est
extrêmement louable en effet secteur
d'hébergement temporaire médicalisé des
personnes âgées n'arrive pas à décoller
entre guillemets tandis que celle des
personnes handicapées est en plein essor
l'objectif consiste donc à étendre les
dispositions réglementaires relatives à
l'hébergement temporaire des personnes
handicapées à celui des personnes âgées
cependant et c'est bien dommage ce n'est
pas à la loi de prévoir qu'un décret
doit adapter les dispositions
réglementaires c'est ce que nous avions
dit en commission avec madame la
ministre
mais la commission ne souhaite donc
madame la ministre s'engage à procéder
rapidement aux modifications
réglementaires nécessaires et c'est une
demande de retrait madame la ministre
alors monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs tout d'abord sur
l'amendement 1134 votre commission a en
effet adopté une disposition
prévoyant une expérimentation comparatif
de plusieurs modalités de fonctionnement
et de tarification pour l'accueil
temporaire médicalisé des personnes
âgées votre amendement prévoit de
supprimer cette phase expérimentale
préalable pour autoriser l'adoption
direct d'un texte réglementaire qui
permettra de créer une tarification
attractive pour ce type d'hébergement
je précise que le projet de décret est
d'ores et déjà en cours de préparation
et pourraient être publiés dans des
délais rapides dans des délais rapides
que vous envisagez pour ces raisons je
suis favorable à votre amendement qui
permettra l'adaptation la plus rapide
des dispositions nécessaires sans
attendre les résultats d'une
expérimentation préalable et je remercie
par la même occasion madame hermange
d'avoir suscité cette initiative est de
nous proposer de l'accélérer de la
mettre en oeuvre globalement c'est donc
un avis favorable et une demande de
retrait de l'amendement 980 au profit
dame en 11 134 qui le satisfait bien
alors je vais métro voir d'abord
l'amendement
on s'en prendre quatre y at il des
explications de vote
je n'en vois pas qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté
l'amendement 980 ainsi satisfait
amendement 978 il est présenté par guy
fischer alors avec cet amendement comme
nous l'avons fait pour les états avec
les établissements publics de santé
nous entendons nous opposer à ce que les
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
soient placés sous administration
provisoire à la vue du résultat du
dernier vote sur cet amendement
similaire il me semble que je dois faire
preuve d'une plus grande explication que
ce que nous avons fait pour les hôpitaux
alors notre position est fondée sur ce
que j'aurai envie d'appeler le texte et
le contexte car bien évidemment il peut
arriver que des établissements en
situation de déficit soit placée sous
administration provisoire afin de
permettre à ceux ci de retrouver
l'équilibré mais ce n'est pas cela que
nous dénonçons ce que nous entendons
dénoncer c'est la manière avec laquelle
ce placement sous administration
provisoire est opéré c'est à dire la
manière autoritaire sans concertation ni
information des conseils de surveillance
ou des instances de direction de
l'hôpital ou de l'établissement
d'accueil
nous regrettons parce que là aussi quand
on regarde pour les établissements
médico sociaux on y reviendra peut-être
dans notre explication de votre source
l'article 28 qui est un article capital
emblématique de cette réforme du médico
social
que ce soit à travers tout le mode de
gouvernance
nous regrettons également que le
placement sous tutelle de ces
établissements servent au gouvernement
de stratagèmes pour écarter le débat de
fond
sur les situations de déficit que
connaissent des établissements publics
de santé et les établissements d'accueil
des personnes handicapées et dépendantes
puisque le principe d'une mise sous
tutelle de fils dans à faire croire que
seul le gestionnaire et responsable
écartant ainsi la part de responsabilité
d'un mode de financement à la fois
inappropriée et qui ne nous satisfait
absolument pas une mise sous tutelle que
nous dénonçons d'autant plus que nous
savons pertinemment que la réponse ne
sera jamais rgpp oblige un accroissement
des moyens mais l'application d'une
politique de rigueur dont seront
victimes
les personnels et la qualité des soins
prodigués ou des conditions d'accueil
des personnes âgées dépendantes
merci monsieur le président monsieur
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
donc l'amendement de notre collègue
fisher et du groupe crc spg propose de
supprimer le 25e en de l'article 8 qui a
été introduit par la commission à
l'initiative de notre collègue alain
vasselle cet amendement avait pour objet
de remédier aux lacunes de la procédure
d' alerte déclenchée lorsqu'un
établissement social ou médico-social
connaît une situation financière
difficile
cette mesure reprend donc une
disposition adoptée lors de l'examen du
plfss pour 2009 mais censuré par le
conseil constitutionnel
la commission estime indispensable
d'améliorer la procédure dalle être
aujourd'hui à parfaite et met donc un
avis défavorable à l'ammoniac même
ministre sur les 978
oui monsieur le président mais ma vie
même argumentaire merci je vais te
revoir l'amendement 978 kippour qui
contre il n'est pas adopté deux
amendements discussion commune un
amendement 1123 qui est présenté pour le
groupe socialiste par bernard cazeau
oui il s'agit de l'intervention des
professionnels médicaux et paramédicaux
qui existe qui exerce à titre libéral
dans des établissements et services
sociaux et médico sociaux comme
d'ailleurs ça se fait depuis de très
nombreuses années et c'est absolument
indispensable sinon il y aurait dans
certains petits établissements
l'absence véritablement de peau de deux
médecins et les professionnels de santé
en général
donc nous nous inspirons donc après
l'article 313 4 la rédaction que vous
voyez sur notre amendement chers
collègues l'amendement 147 rectifie
qu'identique n'est pas défendu ils
tombent donc monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis de la commission sur les 11 123
oui monsieur le président merci donc ces
deux les deux amendements en 147
d'adrien gouteyron et on 123 avaient le
même objet s'il vise en fait à préciser
que les établissements sociaux et médico
sociaux doivent pouvoir bénéficier
d'interventions auprès de leurs usagers
de professionnels médicaux et
paramédicaux exerçant à titre libéral
sans que leur intervention ne soient
requalifiés en activité salariée donc
soumises à cotisations sociales
il faut au contraire mes chers collègues
laissée ouverte cette possibilité de
qualification le but de la mesure et
d'éviter la survenue de situations dans
lesquelles on a affaire à de faux
libéraux qui sont en réalité des
salariés et dont l'intervention doit dès
lors être soumises à cotisations
sociales donc un avis défavorable
ce sera contre le ministre oui monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
cet amendement conduit à ce que
l'épreuve et professionnels libéraux
interviennent en complément des
interventions des professionnels
mobilisés par les établissements cela
n'est pas opportun ni en termes de
coordination des soins ni en terme
financier car il y aurait une double
dépenses pour l'assurance maladie
ces établissements ou services ont la
possibilité d'utiliser le forfait est
relatif aux soins qui leur est versé par
l'assurance maladie soit pour recruter
des professionnels salariés soit pour
rémunérer des professionnels libéraux
ce choix se fait en fonction de la
taille de l'établissement de la facilité
qu'il y ait ou non de recruter des
personnels salariés de nombreux
établissements d'ailleurs recours aux
deux solutions une infirmière libérale
intervenant par exemple ponctuellement
pour remplacer une infirmière salariés
absente
votre amendement est donc inutile
j'ajouterai qu'il me paraît même
dangereux
il pourrait en effet conduire empêcher
toute qualification au travail salarié
des interventions de professionnels
libéraux dans ces établissements
cela serait une régression dans ce cadre
le code du travail établit une
présomption de non salariat en faveur
des professionnels immatriculé aux
différents registres et répertoires
professionnels dont les professions
libérales
cette présomption peut être écartée si
un professionnel et dans un lien de
subordination avec un donneur d'ordre et
c'est une protection importante pour le
professionnel c'est pourquoi je vous
demande le retrait sinon avis
défavorable merci mr ministre un
monsieur cazaux autant jésus pour le
salariat dans les cas où c'est possible
autant dans ce cas précis je trouve
qu'on met en danger certains
établissements et donc les les personnes
qui
ils sont hospitalisés dans certains
secteurs c'est pas possible et vous et
vous et vous mettez en danger en ne
laissant pas cette facilité pour mettez
en danger certains établissements qui se
retrouvent requalifier effectivement
mais pour lequel l'ailé les
professionnels de santé ne souhaite pas
parce que ce sont des libéraux être
qualifié comme salarié merci monsieur 15
ou pas d'autres explications de vote jeu
mais trouve un commandement 1123 qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté un amendement 23 équipes ibis
n'est pas défendu ils tombent 3e en en
discussion commune un amendement 1319
rectifié du gouvernement
oui monsieur le président l'article 45
de la loi du 5 mars 2007 instituant le
droit au logement opposable et portant
diverses mesures en faveur de la
cohésion sociale daloa prévu sous
certaines conditions relatives à la
gestion non lucrative de ces
établissements l'application du taux
réduit de tva sur l'investissement dans
les locaux des locaux par don destiné à
accueillir durablement des personnes
adultes handicapées ou âgées ainsi
qu'aux travaux de rénovation de ces
mêmes locaux
il s'agit notamment de maison d'accueil
spécialisée de foyer d'accueil
médicalisé de foyers d'hébergement et de
foyer de vie pour personnes adultes
handicapées qui ne peuvent pas mobiliser
le financement en prêt locatif social
le présent amendement vise à réparer une
lacune de la législation et étant le
taux réduit de tva ou structures
d'hébergement qui accueille des enfants
handicapés
cette extension qui permettra de
faciliter la modernisation des
établissements d'accueil des enfants
handicapés ne rentre pas en
contradiction avec la directive
européenne de 2006 sur la tva à taux
réduit c'est pourquoi je vous propose
d'adopter cet amendement merci à mr
alors un cet amendement 1310 oeuvre qui
vit un sous-amendement monsieur millet
au nom de la commission
oui monsieur le président merci donc
l'amendement du gouvernement réécrit le
grand 2 de l'article 28 introduit par la
commission et qui prévoit d'étendre le
bénéfice du taux réduit de la tva aux
structures d'hébergement temporaire et
d'accueil de jour le gouvernement
propose donc de supprimer ces
dispositions au motif qu'elle serait
contraire au droit communautaire
en effet celui ci n'autorise
l'application du taux réduit de tva que
pour les opérations portant sur des
logements fournis dans le cadre de la
politique sociale selon le gouvernement
les structures d'accueil de jour et
d'hébergement temporaire ne rentrerai
pas dans ce cadre
en revanche l'amendement étend le
dispositif de tva à taux réduit aux
établissements accueillant des mineurs
ou des jeunes adultes handicapés qui
sont
sont injustement exclu aujourd'hui sur
ce sujet donc monsieur le président la
commission souhaite formuler deux
observations
il est vrai que les services d'accueil
de jour ne peuvent être assimilés à des
structures de logement à caractère
social
ils doivent donc être exclus du
dispositif cependant concernant les
structures dédiées à l'hébergement
temporaire celle ci constitue bien une
forme sociale d'habitat et peuvent donc
bénéficier à ce titre du taux réduit de
tva
en conséquence la commission propose un
sous amendement qui supprime les
dispositions qui étendent le taux réduit
de tva à l'accueil de jour mais conserve
son bénéfice pour les établissements
dédiés à l'hébergement temporaire pour
les personnes âgées et les personnes
handicapées et étant comme l'amendement
du gouvernement ce même dispositif aux
établissements pour enfants handicapés
non 1125 qu'il est présenté pour le
groupe socialiste par jean pierre michel
oui merci monsieur président cet
amendement est semblable à ceux du
gouvernement
il tente à corriger une disposition en
oublie la loi sur le logement opposable
et nous nous rallierons à l'amendement
du gouvernement mais nous pensons que
les distinctions de la commission
affaires sociales ne sont pas bonnes
parce que il faut également réduire le
taux sur les événements de jour
provisoire
si monsieur michel alors monsieur le
rapporteur votre vie sur l'amendement du
gouvernement vous voulez donner un peu
sur l'amendement de monsieur michel
douce qui devra l'assumer
c'est pas tout à fait la lecture que
j'avais faite de l'amendement tel qu'il
a faite monsieur michel donc je pensais
que l'amendement de smichet a été
satisfait j'avais pas fait la même
lecture que très bien madame ministre
sur le sous-amendement bien évidemment
un avis très favorable à ce
sous-amendement 2
la commission et du rapporteur qui vient
très utilement compléter et bien le
champ qui va être couverts effectivement
par ces avantages qui vont nous
permettre d'aller encore plus loin dans
l'accompagnement des plus fragiles donc
bien sûr nous soutiendrons et par voie
de conséquence madame la ministre vous
lever le gage qui est aux grands 4 ou le
vélo gages qui est aux grands 4 de la
bbc le président très bien alors pas
d'explications de vote
bréchet de ligny merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mais mes
chers collègues nous soutiendrons bien
sûr ces amendements
nous nous félicitons de la rédaction
mais je voudrais ici me faire
l'interprète entre autres d'un travail
qui a été fait par notre collègue marie
claire lise campion sur l'interprétation
des textes à gré donc financée par les
conseils généraux les élever à
associatif contribuer à l'exercice d'une
mission d'intérêt général ou même titre
que les établissements et les services
mentionnés à l'article l 312 1 du code
de l'action sociale
il devrait donc relever de la sixième
directive européenne 77 388 c'est eux
qui prévoit dans son article 13 h
d'exonérer de tva
certaines activités d'intérêt général
dont le caractère social est reconnue il
apparaît très donc qu'il soit possible
dans le cadre d'une démarche autre que
celle qui est évoquée aujourd'hui
d'aboutir à une tva réduite pour les
lieux de vie et d'accueil
je voudrais interrogé madame la ministre
sur cette possibilité très bien vu est
ce qu'il y a
d'autres interventions d'autres
explications je n'en vois pas je vais
donc on est renvoie d'abord
sous-amendement qu'a présenté le
rapporteur 1353 rectifié kippour qui
contre il est adopté je vais donc mettre
on voit l'amendement 1319 rectifié du
gouvernement ainsi sous-amendé kippour
qu'ils comprennent je n'en a pas il est
adopté et l'amendement 125 est donc
satisfait un amendement du gouvernement
1169 qui est le dernier amendement sur
l'article 28 de la ministre
oui monsieur le président je renvoie en
fait à la discussion que nous avons eue
tout à l'heure je ne vais pas repréciser
l'argumentaire encore une fois
simplement dire que si sur le fond nous
partageons complètement la nécessité de
faire en sorte encore une fois de
protéger des usagers dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
nous proposons de le faire après bien
sûr un travail préparatoire qui nous
permettrait d'en définir les conditions
loin d'y être opposé nous souhaitons y
mettre les conditions de consultation
maximum merci on a mis ce monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le président la philosophie n'a
pas changé donc c'est toujours un avis
défavorable pour cette un moment là très
bien je vais trop voir l'amendement en
169 du gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour et qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté nous en avons ainsi mes chers
collègues achevé l'examen des
amendements de lartigue raid pit nous
allons passer maintenant au vote de
l'article 28 pour lesquelles je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public et
sur lequel je suppose donc vous pouvez
vous préparer et sur lequel je suis tu
poses ira se vendent des caricatures de
vote
monsieur fisher monsieur de dénis je
n'en vois pas d'autre pour l'instant
chez vous avez la parole oui c'est un
article très important puisque il des il
redéfinit la gouvernance des
établissements médico-sociaux et en fait
ils proposent plusieurs réformes dans ce
domaine du médico social et notamment
afin de tirer les conséquences de la
nouvelle gauche
ans instaurée par les agences régionales
de santé
donc pour notre part nous voulons faire
nous faire l'écho bon des inquiétudes
que nous avons déjà maintes fois évoqué
mais qui à la lumière de l'actualité
peuvent prendre dans d'autres enceintes
et bien une certaine tonalité
vous savez que à l'heure actuelle porte
de versailles se tient actuellement le
salon gérons de géronte expo handicap
et bien entendu c'est le l'occasion de
rassembler tous les professionnels les
usagers
toutes les entreprises bien entre eux
qui travaillent dans ce secteur et je
crois que l'écho qui en qui ressort est
bien c'est que professionnels et usagers
ne cesse de dénoncer la baisse des
moyens alloués à la prise en charge de
la dépendance et je crois que cet éco
général est en totale contradiction même
si madame la ministre à plusieurs
reprises nous a dit qu il y avait eu des
fonds importants plus de 900 millions
d'euros qui avait été injectée mais
certainement que par rapport aux besoins
à satisfaire aux retards accumulés au
fil des ans un seul reconnaît bien
volontiers
et bien il y à un mécontentement une
inquiétude vif et ce qui a été dit à ce
autour du moins ce qui ressort de ce qui
se dit dans ce salon c'est que les
retraités leurs familles ainsi que les
organisations représentatives
d'hébergement des personnes âgées alors
que ce soit ça peut être les grandes
associations les hôpitaux les maisons de
retraite ont fermement dénoncé le sous
financement du secteur madame la
ministre
des inquiétudes fortes pèsent alors que
les moyens vont b
c'est par le biais du mécanisme des
mécanismes budgétaires alors c'est
gérard vincent le délégué général de la
fédération hospitalière de france qui
l'a dit il serait temps que les pouvoirs
publics étudient les besoins des
personnes âgées avant d'allouer des
budgets là c'est joël le gall de la
fnapaef une association de personnes
âgées le coup de moyen d'une maison de
retraite avoisine les 10 700 euros
sachant que depuis 2000 des 2000 les
tarifs augmentent de 5% par an c'est une
moyenne
alors que le montant moyen de la
retraite des personnes âgées
bon des familles de personnes aussi
handicapé etc
le montant moyen de la retraite est de
11 100 euros et on sait que pour les
générations qui viennent on va assister
à un écrasement des retraites
ce sera certainement le corps du débat
dans en 2010 sur les retraites
et puis une réalité dont on a conscience
aussi les directeurs des établissements
alors là c'est pascal champvert qui
parle qui s'inquiète particulièrement de
la non mais je le rappelle parce que
vous pouvez monsieur monsieur vasselle
repoussé tenir par le mépris tout ce qui
se dit mais non non non non mais bon je
vous ai vu faire là je vous ai vu faire
et je vous connais trop pour savoir que
c'était du mépris 1
alors alors pas ceux de north bay pascal
champvert voilà ce qu'il dit et
s'inquiètent mais ça ça vous concerne
directement monsieur le futur non
monsieur le futur rapporteur général des
finances sociales et bien voilà ce qu'il
dit pascal champvert et s'inquiète
particulièrement de la circulaire
ministérielle circulaire parce que les
mauvais coups se font si par circulaire
ministérielle établissant la convergence
tarifaire qui va se traduire pour 90 %
des établissements par une baisse de
moyens et des effectifs inacceptable
alors quand on connaît la réalité les
établissements les mieux lotis
actuellement affiche un ratio de 0,6
personnel pour un résident cela
représente pour une aide soignante pour
12 personnes âgées et 15 minutes par
toilettes et on va rogner là dessus
s'insurge claude jarry de la fnadepa et
je termine par didier sapy alors qu'ils
aient représente une autre association
qui est en totale contradiction avec le
discours tandis que alain ville est ce
que nous connaissons bien
au sein de cette commission des affaires
sociales alors qu on dit qu'il faut
s'attaquer au reste à charge des
patients et de leurs familles bien
entendu la convergence va alourdir les
tarifs d'hébergement
il y a urgence à recréer un cinquième
risque
mais c'est pas la loi que nous mitonne
messieurs vasselle et marini qui va
régler les problèmes au contraire on
ajoutera tout cela sur le dos des
familles merci mon cher collègue la
parole pour l'explication de vote et cas
yves daudigny
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues nous ne
pourrons pas approuver cet article 28 et
je me dis quand je fais le constat qu'un
membre éminent compétents de cette
assemblée dont la presse nationale
annoncée hier
l'entrée prochaine probable sinon
possible au gouvernement a signé un
amendement dont l'objet comporte les
deux phrases cette disposition tend à
instaurer une forme de tutelle de l'état
sur le département
un peu plus loin ce qui peut s'analyser
en une forme de recentralisation peu
justifiable et en tout état de cause
incompatible avec les lois de
décentralisation
je me dis que les arguments que nous
avons présentées au cours de ce débat
n'était peut-être pas aussi à fond dès
que cela a été soutenu et j'en viens à
me demander si dans le fond ce projet de
loi n'est pas celui des rendez vous
manqué un rendez vous manqué avec les
professions médicales mais ce n'est pas
l'objet de l'article 28
et puis aujourd'hui un rendez vous
manqué avec les collectivités
territoriales
ce projet était pourtant bien à
l'occasion d'approfondir de conforter
les lois de décentralisation dans ce
domaine essentiel du médico-social de
préciser des procédures qui aujourd'hui
c'est vrai quelquefois sont floues de
construire des partenariats sur la base
du respect mutuel de respect mutuel des
compétences de chacun et la voie était
ouverte elle été poussée possible je les
dis hier soir ces deux voies
c'était une démarche conjointe pour
l'élaboration des schémas démarche
conjointe pour les schémas qui pouvait
ensuite être suivie d'une concertation
je dirais simple pour l'élaboration des
priac ainsi les compétences des conseils
généraux n'étaient pas atteintes et
ainsi l'état garder aussi toutes ses
prérogatives en matière financière
alors vous ne l'avez pas voulu vous
n'avez pas souhaité donc un rendez vous
manqué et parce que l'intérêt général
prime sur toute autre considération
je voudrais simplement cet instant formé
le souhait que l'ensemble du projet de
loi ne soit pas lui
un rendez vous manqué avec la santé des
français merci monsieur ennjimi pour
expliquer sur l'autre le par l'état
jacques blanc oui monsieur le président
je crois que ce texte au travail de la
commission et je tiens à souligner
combien il a été précieux
l'ouverture du gouvernement eh bien ces
deux éléments ont permis
incontestablement d'aller vers un mieux
une réponse le plus adapté à une action
sociale qui est toujours complexe et
difficile notre pays peut être fier de
ce que l'on fait dans ce domaine
articulé l'action à la fois de l'état et
le rôle reconnu c'était à l'article 26
mai ça des incidences sur cet article
le rôle reconnu au département en
particulier grâce à l'amendement que
vous avez su madame secrétaires d'état a
proposé un accord avec la commission au
regard il ya là me semble-t-il une
démonstration que le travail au sénat
avec la volonté du gouvernement a permis
incontestablement de faire avancer les
choses de répondre aux interrogations
que qui étaient nombreuses dans le
département de répondre aussi aux
interrogations des associations je me
réjouis mais c'est un mérite du
rapporteur et de la commission avec
l'accord du gouvernement que par exemple
sur eux
les appels à projets la procédure
relative au renouvellement des agréments
ne soit pas rentrée dans ce nouveau
système parce que ça risquait de
compliquer les choses
mais que par contre la procédure d'appel
à projets permettra aux associations en
particulier qui portent des ambitions
qui ont envie d'expérimenter d'aller
plus loin pour répondre aux problèmes et
des handicapés de le faire avec beaucoup
plus de sérénité parce que quand vous
aviez un agrément et que vous n'étiez
pas sûr d'avoir les financements après
vous étiez dans des situations pour le
moins complexe et chacun que tous ceux
qui ont expérimenté
les cross se trouvaient souvent dans des
situations extrêmement difficiles donc
il ya des progrès considérables qui sont
apportés ou permettrait à l'ancien
rapporteur d'une loi ancienne celle de
75 des cas quand même été un fondement
de la politique en faveur des personnes
handicapées on peut en être fier en tous
les cas moi voyez au bout de nombreuses
années je ne suis toujours très fiers la
preuve est bien de dire que j'ai le
sentiment que on a avancé pour prendre
en compte la réalité des situations de
handicap et ceux qui doivent être
poussées pour s'insérer au maximum dans
notre société
ce dont le degré d'handicap exige une
prise en charge réelle dans des
établissements mais des établissements
qui ne sont pas fermées je souhaite
aussi que l'amendement qu'on vient de
voter demande à mme hermange sur les
établissements temporaire puisse
concerner des handicapés par exemple
chacun sait bien que handicapé dans sa
famille il ya des moments d'intolérance
et qu'on a besoin d'un séjour de rupture
sans que obligatoirement ça soit un
séjour dans un établissement spécialisé
psychiatrique
c'est le cas aussi parfois dans les
établissements où il ya des situations
qui sont des situations qui ont besoin
là aussi d'un changement là aussi d'un
séjour de rupture
je souhaite donc ce qui a été voté sur
les accueils temporaires puisse
concerner ces personnes ces deux types
d'établissements
donc c'est un travail considérable qui a
été fait vous pouvez je pense vraiment
madame le ministre
être fier de ce qui se fait et nous nous
sommes très fiers de ce que fait le
sénat et en particulier notre commission
et notre rapporteur et donc nous
voterons cet article mais si on chers
collègues - crispation de voeux
monsieur autun puis le rapporteur a
demandé la parole et la ministre et nous
passerons votre université le président
mesdames les ministres mes chers
collègues cet article 28 s'inscrit dans
une politique avec laquelle
effectivement nous ne pouvons pas être
d'accord
elle est dans le prolongement d'ailleurs
des lois de finances cette finance des
lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2009 qui comportait déjà
des dispositions tarifaires lourde de
conséquences pour le secteur et cette
réforme l'article 28 témoigne une fois
de plus que les personnes accompagnaient
où les usagers ne sont plus au coeur des
dispositifs la logique de cette réforme
et des réformes qu'ils l'ont précédé
remet profondément en cause les
fondements de la procédure budgétaire
est en effet initialement basée sur les
besoins d'accompagnement des personnes
à présent il s'agit nous l'avons
dénoncée à maintes reprises notamment
pour l'hôpital mais c'est aussi vrai en
ce qui concerne le médico social
il s'agit d'une politique purement
financière et comptable si nous
comprenons bien sur la nécessité de
mieux maîtriser la dépense publique nous
pouvons néanmoins accepté que ses
arbitrages se fasse au détriment des
personnes concernées enfin ce que nous
devons déplorer aussi c'est le manque de
concertation avec le secteur médico
social tandis que la remise en cause de
la régulation budgétaire tarifaires et
financière se précipitent aucune
véritable concertation avec le secteur
n'a eu lieu
cette situation est dénoncée bien
entendu partout les tout et associations
travaillant deux dans ce secteur c'est
une raison supplémentaire qui vient
compléter l'intervention de mon collègue
et ami eddie fisher qui nous amène à
voter contre cet article 28
monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur le
président je voudrais juste intervenir
pour rectifier des propos tenus par
notre collègue daudigny au sujet d'un
présent d'un président de groupe
ministrable son après ce qu'on lui ceux
d'ordre ce qu'on lui souhaite parce que
c'est un homme de valeur juste dire que
ce président de groupe hier soir qui a
parlé dans un serment demande heureuse
de recentralisation peu justifiable au
niveau de l'article 28 à retirer cet
amendement en disant clairement que s'il
retirait c'est parce qu'il ne pouvait
faire référence à l'article 26 où nous
parlions de concertation et qu'il avait
fait la confusion entre les deux il s'en
est excusé et auprès du gouvernement et
auprès de l'assemblée et donc je tiens
ici à rectifier ce qui a pu dire
monsieur badini sur ce collègue madame
la ministre
oui monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs avant peut-être
de commencer mon propos de conclusion
bien sûr je me joins à monsieur millions
sur la précision qui vient d'apporter
concernant les positions et les
démarches entamées par monsieur mercier
et bien sûr comme lui je m'inscris en
faux par rapport aux remarques qui ont
été faites
je voudrais redire quand même que jeune
femme je ne peux pas laisser dire que 90
% des établissements vont perdre des
financements alors qu'au travers des
conventions tripartites
nous allons avoir une augmentation de
30% pour 93 % des établissements médico
sociaux d'ici 2012 et s'est d'ores et
déjà entamé puisque je l'ait déjà
rappelé au cours de ce débat il y a eu
300 millions d'euros dans le cadre du
budget 2008 qui ont été affectés pour la
création de dix mille emplois soignants
supplémentaire pour les établissements
pour personnes âgées déjà existants dix
mille emplois supplémentaires en 2009 ça
fait vingt mille sur deux ans donc deux
fois 300 millions d'euros et pérenne
puisque c'est du personnel donc 600
millions d'euros supplémentaires en
personnel soignant dans les
établissements qui fonctionne déjà
si ça c'est une réduction des moyens
permettez moi de vous dire que alors à
ce moment-là on n'emploie plus le même
vocabulaire pour parler des mêmes choses
enfin c'est un peu mon sentiment donc
quand même aussi vous dire que s'il ya
un texte qui vise à aller dans le sens
de l'intérêt général et dans le respect
de la démocratie
là aussi sanitaire et médico-social
c'est quand même ce texte qui vise à
compléter la loi et à préciser la façon
dont la gouvernance et les concertations
vont s'organiser on a eu l'occasion à
maintes reprises en ce débat de rappeler
combien l'ensemble des acteurs y
seraient associés on a eu l'occasion à
maintes reprises de dire que dans
l'élaboration des décrets non seulement
les départements mais les usagers ou
encore les léser les structures
gestionnaires seraient associés à la
préparation de ces décrets
de la même façon lorsque on parle des
usagers qui veulent être au coeur du
dispositif mais des usagers on les
inscrit au coeur du dispositif dans la
loi c'est écrit noir sur blanc
ils seront là aussi dans toutes les
instances de gouvernance on nous dit que
on nous menons une politique purement
financière et comptable je viens de
rappeler que cette politique purement
financière et comptable elle les met
dans le sens positif dans le sens de la
hausse en ce qui concerne le champ
médico-social convient d'aborder et
concernant l'article 28
donc oui elle est financière et
comptable elle vise à plus de qualité
mais pas seulement au niveau d'une autre
organisation de la gouvernance mais
aussi au niveau des moyens qui sont
octroyés non pas dans le texte hôpital
là mais bien dans le plfss et dont les
différents textes qui seront abordés
parallèlement vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir monsieur fisher que le président
a rappelé son souci de voir traiter la
question du reste à charge dans le
paiement des places en établissement des
personnes âgées ça fera l'objet vous le
savez d'un autre débat parlementaire
enfin quand on me dit qu'il n'ya pas de
concertation avec le secteur
médico-social monsieur autun je me
permets de vous rappeler comme je les
dis à votre collègue annie david que
j'ai reçus personnellement au ministère
l'ensemble du champ médico-social les
acteurs des personnes âgées des
personnes handicapées les partenaires
sociaux et les départements et on a
satisfait à toutes les demandes les plus
importantes qui se sont exprimés ils ont
besoin maintenant d'être sécurisée sur
les points qui relève du décret je me
suis engagé à les concertée et donc il
me semble que nous avons pu tenir nos
engagements en tout cas faire en sorte
que comme nous l'avions dit au départ de
ce texte le médico social soit préservée
soit sécurisée tout en étant
décloisonner dans l'intérêt d'un travail
en filières face à une augmentation de
la grande dépendance des personnes âgées
est une véritable nécessité aussi
d'améliorer la transversalité de nos
politiques que ce soit en faveur du
handicap comme de la dépendance
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
tout cas je pense que grâce à vous
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs à vous
tous à vous monsieur le rapporteur
bien sûr bien sûr
eh bien nous avons pu avancer monsieur
blanc je voulais vous dire que vous avez
effectivement est acteur d'un texte qui
a été fondateur comme vous l'avez
rappelé que peut-être aussi vous avez
parlé de la tva à 5,5 et d'une
inquiétude je voulais vous rappeler
qu'au travers des deux amendements qui
viennent d'être examinées vous
complètement satisfait et là encore on
voit l'intérêt du travail du sénat de la
commission des affaires sociales et de
tous les sénateurs en tout cas merci
pour cette collaboration tout au long de
ce texte et on voit bien que là encore
une fois la navette parlementaire et le
travail partagé du gouvernement avec le
parlement et bien porte ses fruits
merci merci un ami nice il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement ce qui se douter pour remettre
aux secrétaires un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre un
bulletin bleu ceux qui souhaitent
obtenir un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
je
à
teint est ouvert
aie aie
car
oh j'ai invité à risque les secrétaires
a procédé au dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro 72 sur
l'article 28 nombre de votants 341
nombre de suffrages exprimés 339
majorité absolue 170 pour l'adoption 188
contre 151 le sénat a adopté l'article
28 bis à nouveau il n'y a pas
d'amendement je considère donc comme
adopté article 28 bis j'ai un amendement
1251 du gouvernement madame les
ministres c'est un amendement technique
d'abord monsieur le président mes
salutations matinale as i came down et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
je me réjouis de cette nouvelle journée
de travail en votre compagnie et
l'amande bauchi merci monsieur gournac
aux arrêts public comme vous monsieur
vie chère alors cette amende non veut
permettre à l' agence des systèmes
d'information partagés
l'asip de financer des projets l'asie
pour à assier des projets régionaux par
exemple à mettre leurs procédures en
conformité avec le cadre
d'interopérabilité ou à faire réaliser
des développements et cahier des charges
qui bénéficieront à tous les projets
régionaux constituent le socle sur
lequel s'appuiera le déploiement du dmp
cette possibilité de financement
je dois l'avouer ne correspond
d'ailleurs pas franchement à une
innovation puisque le gip dmp dont cette
agence est issu finançait déjà des
projets régionaux
il s'agit simplement d'asseoir ses
financements sur une base juridique plus
adéquat
voilà le sens de l'amendement que je
vous propose mes yeux
merci à marie ce monsieur le rapporteur
et danse est un avis extrêmement
favorable merci je ne vois pas
d'explications de vote je me vois cet
amendement 1250 est inquiet pour hill et
qui contre il est adopté l'article 28
bis est adoptée dans les mêmes
conditions
je vous en remercie alors un article 28
bis bis nouveau pas d'amendement il est
adopté nous en arrivons chaupitre qu'un
article 29 amendement 254 actifs y est
qu'ils présentaient par notre collègue
alain gournac monsieur le président
madame la ministre avec madame pro
cassia nous souhaitons bien organiser
des périodes où il n'ya le directeur
serait parti l'autre encore à arriver et
donc de prévoir cette vacance qu'est ce
qui va se passer si nous sommes parce
qu'il est impensable qu'il n'y ait pas
de direction vraiment impensable
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
cette période que nous souhaitons
d'ailleurs courte puisqu'on prévoit lé
dans notre proposition que ce soit une
organisation plus de quatre mois pendant
quatre mois
comment nous allons désigner le
directeur général par intérim par attire
il ne s'est pas du quart et le poste
donc voilà le but amendement avec madame
procas ya en cas de vacance des
fonctions de directeur général le
directeur général de l'agencé régionale
de santé désigne pour une durée d'au
plus quatre mois un directeur général à
titre intérimaire après avis du
président du conseil d'administration et
de la fédération nationale des centres
de lutte contre le cancer
plus représentatif voilà notre
amendement il monsieur benoît xvi durant
porter monsieur le président la
commission a considéré qu'il s'agirait
peut-être d'un problème réglementaire
est donc un avis telle demande talent
donne donc un avis sagesse en attendant
l'avis du gouvernement train je suis
favorable à cet amendement qui vient 13
heureusement combler un vide juridique
actuellement dans le code de la santé
publique donc je sais mais un avis
favorable
très bien y at il des explications de
vote sur l'amendement 253 rectifié je
n'en vois pas qui pour qui contre il est
adopté un moment 1145 il est présenté
par madame payet
merci monsieur le président l'article 29
redéfini les missions des caisses
régionales d'assurance maladie qui sont
désormais renommé caisse régionale
d'assurance retraite et de protection de
la santé au travail le texte adopté en
commission à modifier le nom des caisses
pour le transformer en caisse de
retraite des accidents du travail et des
maladies professionnelles conservant les
initiales g
toutefois ce sigle assimilée par les
usagers au régime d'assurance maladie
continuera d'introduire une confusion le
présent amendement a pour objet de
proposer une appellation plus simples
permettant d'éviter toute confusion
celle de quart en outre elle s'appuie
sur l'expression assurance retraite
fortement valorisée dans la
communication du régime général depuis
plusieurs années les rapporteurs
messieurs président la commission a
prévu une nouvelle dénomination des
caisses régionales permettant de ne pas
modifier l'acronyme g sur lequel elles
sont connues et permettant ainsi
d'éviter les frais afférents à un
changement de logo avait donc émis un
avis défavorable à l'amendement séquence
merci monsieur l'un porteur madame la
ministre je vais me permettre de mettre
un avis favorable parce que je trouve
que c'est une scène c'est une bonne idée
qui risque qui va entraîner l'abolition
justement d'un risque de confusion et de
préserver l'acronyme crap
justement je ne suis pas d'accord avec
le rapporteur présente justement le
risque d'introduire cette confusion chez
des usagers qui pourrait penser que les
caisses que ses caisses continue
d'intervenir dans le champ de
l'assurance maladie et donc je trouve la
proposition très très opportune merci
ministre je ne vois pas d'explication de
votre si monsieur que zhu en ce qui nous
concerne nous trouvons l'amendement de
madame payet extrêmement judicieux
parce que c'est la confusion
effectivement avec le sigle cram qui ne
représentera plus la même chose qu'il
faut éviter donc nous voterons stands
non merci monsieur zhu ce ne doit pas de
trucs indications de vantch 20 m au
droit d'amendement 1145 qui et pour qui
contre ils étaient 2 pts et un
amendement 17 rectifié qui est présenté
par gérard dériot oui monsieur le
président les partenaires sociaux ont
conclu le 5 avril 2006 un accord relatif
à la gouvernance de la branche accidents
du travail et maladies professionnelles
qui prévoit d'instituer au niveau
régional un strict paritarisme et de
mettre en place une commission régionale
associant des membres du conseil
d'administration et des membres des
comités techniques dans le cadre de
l'évolution des caisses régionales il
est important de réaffirmer le rôle des
caisses régionales dans la branche
accidents du travail et maladies
professionnelles
et de pouvoir préciser la gouvernance de
cette branche au niveau régional en
transposant les deux mesures souhaitées
par les partenaires sociaux la présente
mesure prévoit donc d'une part que seuls
les partenaires sociaux disposent du
droit de vote au sein du conseil
d'administration des caisses régionales
dès lors qu'il est question de sujets
relatifs à la branche accidents du
travail et maladies professionnelles et
d'autre part la création d'une
commission des accidents du travail et
maladies professionnelles régionales
dont les membres sont désignés parmi les
membres titulaires et suppléants du
conseil d'administration et des comités
techniques régionaux tel est le but de
cet amendement
merci merci ancien collègue monsieur ne
rapporte la venue de la commission
alors le président cet amendement qui
transcrit à des scores et d'accords
relatifs et la branche accidents du
travail maladies professionnelles
contribuera certainement à favoriser le
recentrage des j'avais écrit cram mais
maintenant je sais plus ce qu'il faut
mettre caisse d'assurance retraite de la
santé au travail sur leur nouveau coeur
de métier et donc c'est un avis très
favorable
istres savoir applique même avis je mets
au voile amendement 17 rectifié kippour
qui comprend il est adopté un amendement
du gouvernement 1280 madame la ministre
oui c'est un dispositif transitoire pour
conserver les zonages existants et les
dispositifs de régulation qui s'appuie
sur ces zonages
on pense en particulier aux dispositifs
de régulation qui est incluse dans la
convention infirmière depuis fin avril
on a d'ailleurs largement parlé dans nos
débats et ce jusqu'en juillet 2012 les
zones sont définies par les mrs pour les
médecins généralistes et pour les
infirmiers libéraux et il faut
évidemment assurer la continuité des
politiques menées et cet amendement a
pour objet de conserver une base légale
à ces zonages et de donner la
possibilité aux directeurs de la rs de
le faire évoluer de les faire évoluer ou
d'en définir de nouvelles pendant la
période intermédiaire entre la mise en
place des ars et la publication des
nouveaux schémas des nouveaux soc
donc c'est une mesure de sas pour
permettre de continuer à fonctionner
merci à nos miss saône rapporte ce
président a priori l'abrogation de
l'article 62 47 du code de sécurité
sociale ne devrait pas privé
rétroactivement de base légale des
dispositions conventionnelles qui se
fonde sur ses dispositions
mais le texte proposé constitue une
utile précautions pour apaiser toute
inquiétude à ce sujet et garantir la
continuité de la politique menée c'est
donc un avis favorable
l'explication woerth à paul blanc oui
jouvray madame la ministre vous
remercier de cet amendement qui me
paraît extrêmement important et qui
répondent à une de mes préoccupations à
savoir qu' on puisse continuer à
déterminer des zones qui permettent de
classer certains territoires en zones
sous médicalisées
j'aimerais quand même que vous puissiez
nous donner quelques assurances sur la
nomination rapide des ars parce que si
j'ai bien compris dans votre texte
il faut que les ars soit en place le
directeur soit mis en place
qu'il puisse donc continuer à établir
éventuellement de zonage
en attendant que le dispositif total de
l'agencé soit réalisée et donc il me
paraît indispensable que les ars soit
nommé rapidement de façon à ce qu'on
puisse agir dans ce sens là je vous
remercie de la précision que vous
voudrez bien ma portée madame le
ministre
oui merci cher paul blanc de cette
demande d'information les ars seront
évidemment opérationnelle au 1er janvier
2010 pour éviter tout tout problème mais
les ars préfigurateurs seront recrutés
évidemment dès la promulgation de la loi
merci je mets aux voix l'amendement 1280
qui est pour et qui est contre un il est
adopté
shvedova l'arctique 29 tel qu'il a été
amendé kippour qui compte 30
il est adopté vous venez de suivre
l'examen du projet de loi hôpital
patients santé et territoires prochain
rendez vous avec les travaux
parlementaires cet après midi 15 heures
avec les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt sur public sénat